Marvel's in trouble this once
Untouchable Titan of a franchise has
fallen to its knees in recent years and
it's gotten people wondering should the
MCU just scrap it all and reboot well
today I have the answer and that answer
is us these Theory channels Marvel needs
to run more like US settle in as we give
Mickey Mouse a speedrun lesson on the
art of running a Content
business hello Internet welcome to film
Theory where today it's time to show a
scrappy bunch of YouTubers are smarter
than entertainment's biggest brand so I
don't think it's a controversial take
when I say that Marvel's really
struggling right now box office returns
and Disney plus viewership are in the
tank and there's really no sign of it
turning around the recently concluded
Loki premiered to 40% lower watch
minutes and a fifth of the online
chatter when compared to season 1 that's
pretty bad considering the show before
that secret Invasion had the second
worst numbers of any MCU Disney plus
Series in fact release after release
after release has seen a decline in
overall viewership for the MCU
extensions happening over on Disney plus
but what's more concerning are the films
multiversa Madness disappointment love
and thunder disappointment Quantum Mania
huge disappointment and while the
numbers are still coming in as I write
this the Marvel's is headed for the
lowest opening of any MCU project ever
and that's including the Hulk movie from
way back before this whole thing even
got off the ground early data for the
Marvels is comparing it to the
performance of The Flash let's just say
that you do not want to be compared to
the box office performance of The Flash
in short things are not looking so hot
for this once Untouchable franchise and
it's gotten a lot of people to start
asking is it time for the MCU to reboot
and really is this even that surprising
a question to ask quality of the output
aside the MCU is very long in the tooth
at this point especially when you're
talking about a film franchise whether
it's a soft reboot with a fresh creative
team a hard reboot where they start from
scratch or some mix of both movie series
don't go on this long without some sort
of Fresh coat of paint talks have even
gotten so serious that rumors are now
spreading that they're considering
bringing both Robert down Jr and Chris
Evans back to reprise their roles in a
desperate bid to bring audiences back to
the franchise but here's the thing after
looking deep into the problems that
Marvel's facing right now I'm convinced
that a reboot would be the single worst
idea that they could do at this point so
today friends I'm going to be taking a
deep hard look at Marvel Studios and how
they've been handling their Cinematic
Universe and then give them some advice
on how they can write the ship because
the answers that they're looking for
right now are actually a lot closer than
they expect they're right here on this
channel a few months ago I gave Disney a
free Consulting session on our YouTube
business can fix their movie business
and it looks like it's time for another
session covering a brand new slate of
topics Bob Iger you and your
shareholders might want to start taking
notes or you could always just invest
those billions of dollars over here to a
team who actually knows what they're
doing so grab your popcorns for this one
friends cuz let's be honest you're not
going to be eating it in theaters
watching the Marvels this weekend and
let's dunk on Disney just a little bit
shall we so the issues that Marvel's
facing right now can really boil down
into three main buckets person
centricity programming Cadence and
audience trust so let's let's just take
them Point by point and see where we can
fix things shall we main problem number
one person centricity basically what
this means is that there's one person in
the company who is way too important for
the business to be growing sustainably
you see despite some corporate meddling
here and there the way Marvel Studios
has operated has come down to what Kevin
feige decides his best it's either his
way or the highway with all the
decisions ultimately funneling up to him
and this is true at all points in
Marvel's production several writers and
directors like Edgar Wright and Scott
derkson left their projects due to
creative differences with feige other
directors like and dasta admitted that
they didn't have any creative control
over their work all of this was an
intentional structural decision fige was
frustrated by the lack of control that
Marvel had over their projects pre MCU
quoted as saying we suggested but they
didn't listen we didn't have control I
hated that and you know what for a while
this structure worked there are a lot of
advantages to this sort of arrangement
when you have a figure head like this
you have a consistent guiding force the
person gathers a lot of institutional
knowledge and make sure that
everything's focused in the right
direction because it's their sole
creative decision they and the brand are
united as one which makes sure that
everything feels cohesive and when the
MCU was running at a much smaller scale
just a couple films a year all leading
to a giant crossover having that sort of
singular Vision worked and when you
think about it this is actually the same
model that most YouTube businesses start
off with there's one Central figurehead
that's the centerpiece for the brand the
one responsible for making all the
decisions for Mr Beast it's Jimmy for
mythical it's Rett and Link for MKBHD
that's Marquez and for all of us here at
theorist it's me and often times
everything gets funneled up through the
company to these Central figures who
then is responsible for making the
decisions and just like with Kevin FY
there's a lot of efficiency in that
process because these people know their
brand they know the content they know
their Community better than anyone else
oh this worked really well for our
thumbnails 2 years ago ah people didn't
really care for the episodes when we
scripted it this way oh this is the best
way to do brand deals trust me I've been
doing it for 5 years and uh we've
already done an episode like this we
just did it you know 10 years ago but as
you might imagine there are a lot of
negatives when you're working with that
sort of structure things can become
stagnant without other fresh voices
coming in with new ideas and as the
company grows that person's time becomes
more and more split and quality starts
to dip without some sort of strong
guiding hand at the helm this is where I
see Marvel right now this is a stat I've
pointed to a couple times in the past
but I'm just going to bring it up again
here because it's mindboggling if you
look at the number of minutes of content
released into MCU there's just too much
phase 4 had a staggering 3,500 minutes
spread across 2 years mostly thanks to
the introduction of Disney plus that is
more than phases 1 to three combined and
as a result Kevin feige is losing
control story lines feel disjointed and
it's suddenly difficult for characters
to feel consistent between all the
different projects the first time
viewers felt this was with Wanda going
complete villain from W division to
Doctor Strange even Elizabeth Olsen
wasn't a fan of this and revealed that
it happened because the writers of w
division were given no information about
multiversa Madness the same thing just
happened with Nick Fury's character
between secret Invasion and the Marvels
as film analyst Dan Merl actually said
in his recent review I was thinking this
has to be a variant of the Nick Fury
that was Justin secret invasion
characterization is almost insultingly
180° from the character that we just saw
on that Disney plus series all in all
this seems to be a failure of business
structure information isn't being
properly shared across the people making
the films and shows in the past Kevin
fige would have been the guy passing
that information along but now more and
more cracks and information are starting
to show up as more and more projects are
having to be juggled but thankfully
there are ways to mitigate this issue
main thing I recommend break your
organization down into units each with a
leader who can keep it running smoothly
well it's not really my place to speak
about other YouTube business models I
can give you a peek behind the curtain
here at theorist you see we started
running into the same issue after we
launched food Theory between Game Theory
film Theory food Theory and GT live
writing and overseeing every single
project just wasn't possible for me to
do alone anymore what we ended up doing
was breaking the company down into units
one for each Channel with a creative
director in charge of production and
scripting as well as managing any sort
of crossover events that's why you've
seen people like Lee Tom Amy and Santi
popping up more and more they're the
one's driving a lot of the creative
forward helping choose programming
making sure information and production
quality is at the same level and ideally
higher than it was when I was doing
everything solo cuz honestly it's their
full-time job to keep track of all this
to be experts in all this and the things
that we're talking about it helps us
raise the bar and do more without
spreading ourselves too thin it also
allows us to tackle more big projects
for each Channel like a fashion show on
style Theory or a travel show on Food
Theory or season 2 a game lab over on
Game Theory because now each channel is
able to be its own living breathing
entity Channel all its own with its own
brain in the mode of a creative director
rather than me having to divide my
limited time and resources like some
sort of parent trying to decide which
child gets my attention next it also
lets us start new initiatives much more
easily like social media and podcasts
speaking of we actually did just launch
an audio podcast version of film Theory
over on Spotify if you want to listen to
film theory on the go that right there
that is the best place to do it we have
a ton of our episodes already up there
including some of our Marvel theories
like Thanos was right or whether Thanos
was worthy honestly I'm just a fanos
over here we also have some certified
film Theory Classics in there like our
Disney death count which Disney movie
has the highest death toll listen to
that one and you'll find out regardless
if you're an audio listener and want
some film Theory hits to have on the go
check out the audio version of film
Theory over on Spotify link is down in
the description anyway this is exactly
what Marvel needs to do as a good first
step towards writing their ship break
things down into more manageable
sections Marvel street level Marvel
Cosmic Marvel magic and horror whatever
it is each with a trusted producer
keeping tabs on those characters and
then commuting ating with the other
producers when those characters get
shared then all of that can get run up
the chain to feige for final approval or
any sort of specific notes that he might
have interestingly this is actually
something that Marvel flirted with in
the past and seemed to be doing again
before they fired him James gun was set
up to be the guy in charge of the cosmic
side of Marvel Studios that never
happened it seems though like they might
be trying again as the company just
launched a new Marvel Spotlight Banner
meant to focus on street level
characters that don't need a bunch of
homework to understand no word yet on if
there's a specific producer shepherding
Spotlight to get some of that work off f
plate but hey it's a start in the short
term it might seem like a reboot could
fix this problem yeah completely wiping
the Slate clean would make things much
more approachable for fans and let you
start fresh with characterization you
suddenly don't have to worry about
whether or not a joke Captain America
makes in movie 25 lines up with his
opinions from Movie 3 15 years ago but
this is a short-term solution that still
results in the same issues down the road
if the core structural companywide
problems aren't addressed so in this
case I don't think a reboot would
actually help all that much but this
then leads nicely into problem bucket
number two your programming Cadence when
you're planning out a schedule for any
sort of entertainment nowadays whether
it's a YouTube channel or the MCU you
need to be aware of what you're
releasing and in what order again think
about how to run a YouTube channel the
last thing that you want is to spam your
audience with a bunch of content that
they're not going to be interested in if
you're subscribed to this channel for
film Theory which generally comes out
once a week and has itself a very
specific style if I then start uploading
a bunch of Vlogs about my life you're
going to be pretty mad right or maybe
even less extreme if I start uploading
movie reviews or Easter egg breakdowns
or interviews with celebrities sure some
of you might like some of those because
it's still film related but it's not the
show that you signed up for I'm spamming
most of your feeds with stuff that isn't
going to be interesting to you and bit
by bit you're going to start checking in
on us less and less frequently even
within film Theory itself that's why we
have to be so careful about episode
selection we like to cover everything on
this channel whether it's a big
Blockbuster film in cinemas to an
Undiscovered Indie series on YouTube but
obviously not everyone who watches a PAW
Patrol video are then going to hop on
over to our videos on the back rooms so
within our programming we have to be
careful of delivering you the episodes
that you're most excited about while
also interspersing in things that we
think are cool and might end up being
your new favorite franchise that we
cover this tricky balancing active
programming is actually why it's so hard
to find variety channels on YouTube
anymore it's easiest to just have one
channel do one format on one specific
thing or have one person be the
connective thread on each and every
video all the time because that's what
works easiest for audiences and also
that's what works for the algorithms and
hey Marvel used to be the king of
programming when Guardians the Galaxy
was first announced people thought it
was going to be Marvel's first flop and
for good reason on paper it should have
been an absolute failure they were a
bunch of D listers and they were weird
but Marvel intelligently worked them
into their schedule between a Captain
America movie and an Avengers movie that
way it could soften any bad performance
blow couple that with a solid script and
you know what that movie was a hit and
now everyone loves the Guardians Captain
Marvel roughly the same deal a new
character that they hope to do big
things with moving forward getting
sandwiched between two of the biggest
movies of all time and financially it
worked with a fairly mediocre origin
movie delivering a billion dooll box
office Smash and introducing a
recognizable if not all that beloved new
character into the roster and if you
look at the film output of phase 4 on
paper it looked strong riding off
bangers like endgame and Spider-Man at
the end of phase three we got black
widow Shang XI and the eternals all a
little bit risky but hey you're coming
off of $2 billion hits so it gives you a
couple movies to experiment and guess
what xang XI worked fairly well giving
them a new mid- performing franchise
that they could now work into their
programming slate and then right after
that they had Spider-Man Doctor Strange
Thor black panther four huge franchises
all one after the other to rebuild
momentum after a relatively slow period
except Marvel forgot one thing those
movies weren't the only part of the
conversation anymore with the addition
of Disney plus the films became a much
smaller part of the cultural
conversation instead of all those big
names happening in succession back to
back to back to back those films were
now interspersed between a ton of
smaller shows all of a sudden your Heavy
Hitters aren't getting the room to
breathe and as for the quality of those
Disney Plus shows well for every
certified hit like Loki you had
disappointments like She-Hulk and Falcon
and the Winter Soldier you've got to do
better Senator is this working for
you but what's worse is because the
Disney Plus shows are released over time
instead of all it once the conversation
around them was stretched out for weeks
while the films get a flash in the pan
discussion right after release the shows
they're in the Zeitgeist for months
again looking at the YouTube comparison
that would be like subscribing to this
channel for film Theory giving me a
medium length thoughtfully researched
video every week and US instead spamming
your feed with shorter cheaper less
well-written content every day some made
for you and lots of it not until you
just ually stop watching the channel alt
together for Marvel a reboot here is not
going to solve the problem if you go
into a new rebooted universe and still
program this poorly while you're still
going to spam your viewers you need to
be more Discerning with who you're giv
these Disney Plus shows to while also
working on their overall quality
characters like Loki Wanda Falcon sh it
potentially makes sense to give these
characters shows they've been built up
as Side characters across the films but
does shehulk need a 25 million dollar
per episode series does it make sense to
give M Marvel her show before her debut
in a feature film did Nick Fury need an
ultimately pointless side quest no
Marvel just started making everything
rather than really focusing on creating
the stories that needed to be told which
leads me then to problem bucket number
three audience trust fulfilling on the
promise that you make to your viewers
managing a YouTube channel is a lot like
having a bank account with each video I
do I'm trying to put a deposit into this
Bank of trust with you the viewer I make
a video you like well you trust me a
little bit more to deliver more things
that you like and as a result you trust
my judgment a bit more over years I've
hopefully been able to build a big
deposit with you guys but just like with
a bank account you can also make
withdrawals every time I ask you to do
something that's a withdrawal try a
video on a brand new franchise that
you've never heard of that's a small
withdrawal subscribe to the channel if
you haven't yet small withdrawal go
subscribe to style Theory or go over to
Spotify to check out film Theory's new
channel over there or buy some merch or
watch our premium show on TV which
doesn't exist yet but who knows maybe
one day well all of those are big
withdrawals cuz I'm asking for a lot of
your faith and trust to do something out
of the ordinary for any smart content
creator your job is to maintain that
balance of trust keep putting in
deposits of trust over a long period of
time and make sure that you never
overdraw your account cuz that's when
the audience stops investing and the
biggest draw that you can possibly make
on that account is asking people to
commit to something that you then give
up on we waited literal years to launch
both food and style Theory cuz we wanted
to make sure that we had the systems in
place to deliver those channels
consistently forever the last thing we
wanted was to launch something only to
then let it die leaving you guys with
nothing but a broken promise a betrayal
of your trust back in the day this is
what set the MCU apart from the other
attempted cinematic universes when Nick
Fury stepped out of the shadows and told
Iron Man about the Avengers Initiative
we knew that we were going to be getting
that big crossover when Thanos put on
The Gauntlet and said
fine I'll do it myself we knew that it
was going to pay off and relatively soon
even small things like I can do this all
day is a deposit of trust because it
shows an internal consistent logic of
character that rewards all the longterm
fans of the franchise but these days
because there's new Marvel content
basically every single week and it's all
from such random corners of the MCU
there's been no follow through with so
many of the things that they've teased
that trust is broken there are too many
loose ends that have been left
unresolved there's a giant Celestial in
the ocean that literally no one cares
about moonight had the entire world see
an accelerated day night cycle that's
never mentioned again the Young Avengers
have been teased for so long that really
who even cares anymore team up or don't
I I I just don't care just just move on
and that's just a fraction of the ones
that come to mind from small characters
like the Black Knight to huge issues
like how the Multiverse feels like it
functions differently in almost every
new project these things are breaks in
the audience's trust that tells us well
if Marvel didn't care enough to get it
right why should we and even when they
do explore the exciting Concepts they
introduce it's underwhelming I don't
think anything epitomizes this more than
the Multiverse sure some of it's been
cool we got glimpses of it with Loki and
no way home but most of it just didn't
land remember the hype online when it
looked like they were about to bring in
Quicksilver from the fox movies and then
the payoff was just a bad joke Ralph
boner boner
what if promised to be a bold different
take on all your favorite MCU Heroes and
what we got were 30- minute chunks of
less good versions of movies that we'd
already seen they sold Multiverse of
Madness on this deep dive into weird
worlds like the paint universe and what
we got was a quick montage and 45
minutes in a world identical to the main
MCU with the saturation turned up this
just isn't living up to the promise that
they're giving us the quality isn't
there it'd be like me hyping up our new
apparel is the best stuff ever only for
you to get it and then it be nothing
more than just a run-of-the-mill t-shirt
that's why we put some so much care into
the stuff that we put out because when
you click on a video or buy a jacket or
subscribe to a new channel we want you
to know that your trust hasn't been
misplaced that it's been worth it and
rebooting the MCU right now might be the
single worst decision that they could
possibly make to tackle that problem it
would cause far more harm than good
because it would basically tell us that
everything that we've spent time waiting
for has been for nothing were you
excited to see Sam Wilson tackle what it
means to be Captain America for the next
generation of Heroes to finally take on
the mantle of the Avengers for blade to
fight some vampires a reboot would basic
Al say yeah too bad and make you feel
stupid for wanting those things in the
first place instead just like with the
programming Cadence the solution here is
to just re-evaluate the Slate of films
and shows really double down on what
people are actually excited about and
explore those things to their fullest
potential instead of dangling something
new in every post credit scene like Keys
distracting a dog but here's the big
twist while I've been holding ourselves
up as the model to follow here I
recognize you might be too proud Marvel
to follow the advice of some lowly
YouTuber so you don't have to take my
word for it you can take a look much
closer to home your own comic division
they can also tell you why rebooting
would be a bad idea at this point you
see Marvel has tried rebooting before
with the Ultimate Universe in the early
'90s the comic industry collapsed and
Marvel in particular was hit hard
resulting in their bankruptcy this is
actually when they sold off a lot of
their film rights just to stay afloat
and why we got movies like blade X-men
Spider-Man and Daredevil anyway in an
attempt to drum up excitement for the
brand modernize their characters and
offer Brand New Perspectives on the old
lore Marvel made a bold decision they
were going to start a second Mainline of
comics that would run alongside their
616 universe and they were calling it
Ultimate Marvel basically it was just
them experimenting with rebooting the
whole company at the beginning it ended
up being one of Marvel's biggest success
stories with this universe's Flagship
book The ultimates being the single most
successful comic book of the year but
despite that initial burst of success
the Ultimate Universe quickly petered
out dwindling in sales until the entire
line was eventually cancelled and the
universe destroyed in the secret Wars
event from the mid-2010s the only part
of it that lives on is Miles Morales who
is transferred over to the mainline
Marvel Comics Universe which itself just
continued to chug along the entire time
and still going to this very day a
reboot for the MCU would be the YouTube
equivalent of clickbait or an
unwarranted we need to talk guys video
sure it gets people to click and gets
I'm talking about you again but it's
short term it's a hollow Victory it's a
cheap trick that does worse for the
trust that your audience has in you in
the long term I mean if every new movie
changes everything why should I ever
invest my trust in here in the first
place if the MCU is going to survive it
needs to put in the work to fix its real
problems it needs to give us clear
leadership it needs programming that
makes sense and it needs to fulfill on
the promises that it makes to us its
viewers will that be hard sure but it'll
be far more worth it in the long run
than the short-term solution of just
wiping the Slate clean starting it all
from scratch but hey that's just a
theory a film Theory and
[Music]
cuts